dans la province, répartis
dans près de 290 entrepris
Les indicateurs sont clairs :
le milieu québécois du jeu vidéo
ÉMILIEN ROSCANU, La Guilde
du jeu vidéo du Quidéo du Quidéc
- C'est vraiment un
de nos fleurons au Québec..
- Depuis 2020, 45 nouveaux
studios ont vu le jour
au Québec. Les entreprises
qu'il soit d'ici ou d'ailleurs.
beaucoup d'affichages de postes,
l'immigration, la formation.- Os
à temps plein.
- Il y a six ans, Francis
Lapierre a cofondé son studio
à doubler sa capacité
de production dans
les années à venir.
technique Lucid Dreams Studio
un projet de jeu,
ça prend du temps, c'est
compliqudomaines à combler, tant
au niveau artistique que
technologique, de
- Chaque année, il y a à peupret
des collèges et universités
québécoises.
alors que les opportunités sont
grandissantes dans l'industrie.
BRIGITTE MONNEAU, dir. générale
SYNTHÈSE - Pôle Image Québec
- Il faut former plus de gen
la plus adéquate possible,
compte tsoins très
changeants de ces industries-là.
- Tu vas voir de
, puis tu vas avoir
le côté entrepreneur.- Au festià
Montréal, cette fin de semaine,
les cégeps et universités font
enfants sont nombreux.
FRÉDÉRIQUE CHEVALIER
- C'est plus maman qui fait
le côté étude, puis, lui,
il teste les jeux ches
aujourd'hui.
GAËL
- Je viens m'informer,
je viens essayer des jeux,
es.
PHILIPPE LEGAULT- Ça fait plusie
je viens avec mon garçon, là,
comment dire... c'est une
Je trouve que ça peut être
un bon moyen de lui montrer
peut-être un futur métier
à venir.
- Au pays, les femmes
représen 2021,
23 % de la main d'oeuvre
dans cette industrie.
l'industl'industl'industl'indusi
par : encourager les jeunesfills
à s'intéresser à ces métiers-là.
- Des métiers de l'ombre qui
québécois à travers le monde.
Ici Hadi Hassin,
Radio-C